to point out that a lot of times with
these content creators they're so
focused on what all of the other content
creators are doing they almost Miss
really creating new original content cuz
they're too busy reacting they're too
busy pocket watching every other content
creator known to man it's doing pretty
good it's better than any of your videos
yeah that's for sure any wait what is
the biggest YouTube video you ever
dropped was it Vape Nation back when you
were like still kind of culturally
relevant yeah well it was cool cuz you
used to make stuff and now you just
critique stuff and there's a big
difference between people like me and
people like you yeah what happened I
think everyone that's your fan wants to
know where did it all go wrong I think
people are pretty happy I don't think so
I think a lot of people I mean if you
look at the cultural relevance and
contributions I mean you were
contributing and now you're just kind
of yeah